kriegen wir jemals der regierung wie
geht's weiter in deutschland was bringt
die zukunft wir schalten mal direkt
rüber zu astrotv dort moderierte
schneider vor schneider wissen sie denn
schon heute moment welke
ich habe gerade noch einen anderen
anrufe auf der leitung ja ja lieber höre
da bin ich wieder
ja sie heißen wirklich beamt ich sehe
das hier ganz ganz deutlich in maintal
ja schön dass ich helfen konnte ja sie
heil hitler
arschloch so hellwig was liegt an geht
es wieder darum wann sie endlich das
heute journal moderieren dürfen habe ich
ihnen schon bei den letzten zehn anrufen
gesagt wenn alle anderen moderatoren in
deutschland sind
okay dann muss ich das abwarten aber
sagen sie mal eigentlich hatte ich
gehofft dass sie mir sagen können wie es
mit union und spd jetzt weitergeht
ok ich kann ja mal versuchen in den
eingeweiden der spd zu lesen ich habe
jetzt zufällig das herz der
sozialdemokratie schlägt nicht mehr
schade
ideologisch sind die seit jahren tot
aber der partei körper zuckt noch ein
bisschen vor sich hin
jenseits von mitregieren oder nicht muss
sich die spd endlich mal darauf besinnen
wofür sie erfunden wurde
oder wie es diese
politikwissenschaftlerin ausdrückt wenn
sie jetzt nicht gezeigt werden dann
kriegen die nächste mal zu noch mehr
klatsche wie sie getan
noch mehr klatsche wie jetzt spd höher
auf oma irgendwo irgendwann meistens
recht aber ich wollte von ihnen ja
eigentlich die zukunft wissen oder habe
ich einen tipp für sie fragen sie bloß
nicht martin schulz das ist der
schlechteste wahrsager der welt hier
hören sie mal seine vorhersage kurz vor
der nrw-wahl erzählen man die fehler mit
nach 16 uhr geht der balken nach oben
und heißt es hannelore kraft bleibt mit
der sozialdemokratischen partei
deutschlands die stärkste kraft in
diesem lande
sie bleibt ministerpräsident ja und ganz
klar schaue ich besonders auf diese 18
uhr 1 denn dann heißt es auch die spd
wird die stärkste partei in deutschland
und ich werde bundeskanzler
der mutter war
dabei erfasst alles richtig bis auf das
was er gesagt hat aber wie geht es denn
jetzt weiter mit dem herrn schulz ich
kann ja mal eine glaskugel da kann ich
ja mal rein riechen nicht eindeutig nach
fisch das bedeutet martin schulz wird
als parteichef abgelöst und eröffnet
eine makrelen räucherei in wersen und
weil ich schon weiß was ihre nächste
frage ist pendelt ich jetzt noch schnell
die zukunft von frau merkel aus ja super
so ihr pendel da bewegt sich gar nichts
absoluter stillstand
alles wie immer kurz gesagt merkel
regiert weiter mit irgendwen agoco coco
schoko soko mopo irgendwas mit ist auch
egal
schade und ihre weitere zukunft also was
macht die merkel nach der polit karriere
da kriegt sie laut meiner kugel eine
sendung beim ki ka die heißt
kinderquatsch mit angela ist gerne
vollkornbrot wisst ihr was internet ist
insbesondere baue ich sehr gerne
kartoffeln an und feldhasen mag ich auch
sehr gerne dazu hallo ich mag ihn sehr
gerne
ich mag elefant sehr gerne wisst ihr wer
horst seehofer ist
so wir können dann englisch
wer gut und wer mag keinen spinat will
kann man ihm kaum noch jemand russisch
ich bin ja die drei tiere oder so weiter
alle wieder hinsetzen
das wird super aber schneider wo sie
gerade kika und fernsehen erwähnen noch
mal ganz kurz zum thema heute schon
haben sie herr welke zeit ist um ihr
geld ist alle hallo bin habe ich in der
leitung schade birte schneider meine
damen und herren